voilà dix-huit jours que l'appartement
de sophie zizou taux est vide au-dessus
de la petite mairie de saint romain sur
gourdon 18 jours que cette maman s'est
volatilisé avec ses deux enfants yumi 7
ans et liam 3 ans en ouvrant une
information judiciaire pour disparition
inquiétante
le procureur a désigné un magistrat qui
pourra ordonner d'éventuelles expertises
des analyses pour tenter de trouver plus
d'éléments que le peu dont les
enquêteurs disposent aujourd'hui depuis
la date de sa disparition vous voir
personne n'a eu de ses nouvelles
aucun mouvement sont ses comptes
bancaires sont elles fois mon portable
n'a pas fonctionné aucune aucun contact
message est arrivé non plus sur son
ordinateur
donc on n'a pas beaucoup plus d'éléments
que ceux dont on disposait au moment de
sa disparition un appel à témoins a été
lancé par la gendarmerie il a été
largement relayée par la famille via les
réseaux sociaux notamment
mais aucun des quelques appels reçus n'a
abouti sur une piste sérieuse toutes les
hypothèses restent aujourd'hui possible
y compris une fuite organisée même si
aucun élément ne le laisse supposer
pas même l'audition des proches de
sophie zizou tôt apparemment il ne
connaissait pas d'existence un peu
trouble la lame du couteau il n'avait
pas connaissance de relation bizarre
qu'elle avait au delà de l'inquiétude
centre a surpris de sa disparition
subite et inexpliquée 18 jours après la
disparition de cette famille reste donc
très mystérieuse hier encore une
centaine de personnes se sont réunies
autour du père vincent into par
solidarité et pour l'aider à relier au
maximum l'appel à témoin est l'avis de
recherche